تطبيق تيليجرام محظور في العراق بقرار من
وزاره الاتصالات العراقيه القرار بحسب
بيان للوزاره جاء بناء على توجيهات جهات
عليا ترتبط بالامن الوطني وللحفاظ على
بيانات المواطنين الوزاره تقول انها لم
تتلقى اي تفاعل من شركه تيليجرام حتى بعد
ان كانت قد توجهت مرارا بطلبات اليها
للتعاون في اغلاق منصات تقول انها تتسبب
في تسريب بيانات مؤسسات الدوله الرسميه
والبيانات الشخصيه للمواطنين مما يشكل
خطرا على الامن القومي العراقي والسلم
المجتمعي وعبرت الوزاره عن التزامها بضمان
حقوق المواطنين في التعبير عن ارائهم
والتواصل الحر دون المساس بامن الدوله
ومؤسساتها
بيان وزاره الاتصالات لم يهدئ من روع
العراقيين وتوجساتهم ولم يجب عن تساؤلاتهم
بل اثار مزيدا من التكهنات والتشكيك بين
المواطنين والمستخدمين لم تصدر شركه
تيليجرام اي تعليق او توضيح لكن بعض
الاحزاب السياسيه العراقيه الحاضره بقوه
على تيليجرام جنت هجوما على الحكومه متهمه
اياها بتوظيف الامر السياسيا